so when you did get hired with the view
yeah is it a contract of do they pay in
the format of one episode is it a
six-month contract is it a three-month
contract what's the con agreement um so
I'm trying to remember my contract I
basically had a three-year contract but
at the end of each year they had the
opportunity they had to renew me got it
so
um and there you had a guarantee of a
certain number of appearances I wasn't
employed at ABC at large I was employed
by The View me personally Megan may have
had a different deal how different is
that is that separate yeah because if
you're in it's actually much safer to be
employed by ABC at large because then if
something goes wrong with the view you
can view it a lot that makes sense I
didn't fight for that because at the
time frankly I don't think I had the
credentials to fight for that and
secondly I wasn't sure how it was going
to go and I wasn't sure what was going
to happen so I was comfortable with the
contract they gave me and rolling in and
it was a decent pay was it yes okay so
it was it was it was a raise which was
great
are you still in touch with any of the
ladies on The View whether it's the
conservatives the Abby huntsmans the
mccains the the joy behars the whoopies
I was until this appearance that just
happened I mean I I actually maintained
a a pretty you know decent friendship
um with sunny with Sarah occasionally it
would exchange with Whoopi and joy
um I my time on the show was actually
okay because even though we duked it out
sometimes on air we actually really got
along behind the scenes as a group it
was a cast that really liked each other
yeah so I left and even though I was
fired
inexplicably overnight
um I didn't hold that against the cast
and there were people that worked there
at the time that aren't there anymore
that were responsible for that
um but I left kind of feeling like these
were still my friends and my family and
I was sad so I didn't trash them in
media I didn't do any of that and it
wasn't really until this last appearance
that I just felt like wow that was
pretty horrible what happened on air
because you guys knew what I was going
to say and I I really thought I was
there to have a conversation because I
know them you know Sonny was at my
wedding you know I know these people and
I said if you're going to invite me and
you know what I'm going to say either
say forget it you're not coming on or
let me talk let's have the conversation
she's the biggest Advertiser for the
view do you know like I don't know but I
know you know big Pharma
sorry but can you Google and see who's
the biggest Advertiser on The View I
looked it up in 2015 a bunch of
advertisers dropped but that's not the
article I'm looking for I want as recent
as possible let me go back to it from
the day you got fired how many days
prior to that was when you questioned
Hillary Clinton oh I think it was four I
think I questioned her on a Thursday and
lost my job on a Sunday oh I didn't know
that so four days after you you
questioned Hillary Clinton so what
happened there was and I've spoken about
this with um you know Sunny recently
that we were like no one really
understood what happened there and I
don't know if it's attributed to the
Hillary Clinton interview I really don't
I have no idea what year was that
20s was it 16 17 it's right around there
she was right already or after she lost
no no she was it was after she lost
after she lost she wrote a book called
what happened it was the first live
appearance she did on The View and she
asked the question oh yeah that's right
I saw that which is important question I
had I had just re-upped like that summer
you know you had to like I said they had
to renew you even though you had a
three-year contract they had to renew
you so I signed the paperwork I was like
okay I guess I'm in for another year and
that's the way I view this business you
never know you could be out tomorrow you
know so I was like okay in for another
year
I asked what I thought was a pretty
benign question I asked her I said
listen you know you're saying you're
acting like you're surprised that Trump
won but it sounds a little tone deaf to
me because I was talking to people
around the country who were disgusted
with a lot of what was going on like
looking back do you see that maybe these
people voted because they didn't like
what was happening in the prior
Administration I thought that was a
pretty fair question
her face said otherwise I didn't even
get to ask ask about her emails which
was really what I was there was a little
bit of panic at the show that day
because I was like well can we show here
that she signed a piece of paper that
said she knows what these
classifications mean and she's denied
that she knew them but her signature and
they were like I wouldn't do that I
wouldn't do that there was a little bit
of worry that it was going to be
combative
I think the perception is that but
actually I think there's a lot of
protection that goes on on shows like
that for political figures for point of
views
so I didn't get to that but I I asked
the tone deaf question and then four
days later I actually got a call from
someone who worked in media I think I
think it was Oliver Darcy actually if
I'm not mistaken who wrote who called me
and was like there's a rumor that like
Megan McCain's taking your job and I was
like oh well that can't be I just I was
like what and I wrote my producer and he
was like oh we'll get on it PR I don't
even think the EP of the show knew
no one knew this came from the highway
this came from this is not EP no okay
and my ep's like candy and Brian were
like
really quite nice to me and we're like
listen
I don't know and I believed them and I
still believed them because they're I
really do
um
so I don't know what happened I don't
know if it's related to that I don't
know if that was the icing on the cake I
don't know if there were talks going on
and then suddenly someone decided oh
great and also that interview didn't
help I don't really know it's just the
timing seemed so odd so when did you
when did you sign the next year what
happens in the summer summer how many
like weeks or months before the Hillary
Clinton uh uh it was in August I don't
remember it was several weeks before
that oh so so this is fresh so you sign
it's not like it's six months no no
several weeks it was several weeks got
it so they had already committed to
having you on for another year so it
wasn't like behind closed doors they
were talking to Megan oh my god listen I
maybe for all I know I mean there are
people that have since been fired from
there that were doing pretty horrible
things that's come out in the news
um who I think probably were being
underhanded about it in many ways I
don't know I don't know what
conversations were weren't going on I
just it it kind of changed my perception
of media because I always felt like a
contract was a contract and all of a
sudden I realized which was helpful for
the future like okay you're here today
you could be gone tomorrow so we'll just
keep that in mind some people would say
just be happy you're sitting here
because maybe you pissed off the wrong
person you know because there's certain
people in politics you don't piss off
because they have a reputation you know
that's right and that reputation is a
multi-dimensional type of reputation if
you know what I'm talking about everyone
off so I'm in bad shape maybe I'll come
work here
but we we would love you so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]